today we're gonna explain the evidence
and the subtle clues as to why Kirishima
was the third user of one for all and
how by taking this power it may have led
to him suffering an unimaginable fate
now a couple of months ago I posted a
video explaining why back ago was the
second user one for all and was flooded
with comments specifically asking me if
Kirishima could be the third so this
video will answer how and why that would
be the case as there have been little
hints alluding to it that I'm gonna take
you through however if you've not seen
that Bakugan video then I'd recommend
watching that before you watch this one
but for those of you who like to live
life on the edge let's get into it we
all know that one for all has a total of
nine permanent users with Deku being the
most recent and in a recent chapter in
the manga some new information was
revealed about some of the previous
holders for example the fact that they
didn't really have strong quirks and
that they mostly died at a young age but
it was very interesting to note that two
former users were not included in this
conversation despite searching far and
wide all Mike could find no information
whatsoever on the second and third users
almost as if there was no existing
records of them and on top of that they
were both purposefully blurred out in
previous chapters and the placement of
this speech bubble directly next to back
ago is probably one of the least subtle
hints that horikoshi has ever given us
like guys the bubble is literally
touching him and look at what it says
all might then goes on to say but awful
one was obsessed with one for all and
would seek to destroy anyone who
possessed the power and because one for
all is a stockpiling quirk its power is
built up through the generations with
all my being the first and only user of
one for all to defeat him bearing that
in mind it was not the duty of the
previous holders to defeat all for one
but rather as it says in this panel past
users just had to make sure that their
power would reach the future where one
day it would be strong enough to defeat
him the past users were not chosen ones
but rather they were the ones trusted by
the previous holder this ties into my
back ago theory as I mentioned that one
of the reasons he was sent back in time
was to ensure that one flaw was created
in the first place thus ensuring that it
reaches the future and that's all well
and good but what next back ago is many
things but immortal he is not he knew
that a time would come where eventually
he would have to pass on the power
and it would have to be to someone he
would trust and as we saw at the baton
in Camino there is no one he trusts more
to get him out of a sticky situation
than Kirishima back ago needed someone
he could trust to take the power survive
and keep it safe in a world where all
for one reigns supreme over Japan and
when looking at the third user in this
flashback is pretty clear that he does
have a very distinctive similarity to
Kirishima which a ton of you guys have
mentioned to me in the comments when you
look at the shoulders of their
respective hero costumes let's not beat
around the bush here the gear shape is
literally identical and then let's also
consider this other fact not only have
we never seen another character with
gears besides Kirishima but we know that
more than anyone else the hero who he
most aspires to be is crimson riot you'd
think that if Kirishima was going to
copy someone as far as his hero costume
goes it would be this guy and not his
great-great-great grandfather as I'm
sure many of you are dying to tell me
that this guy is I got enough of those
comments on the back ago video now while
this pineapple hair does look a little
different to cure shame as usual styles
it's not like every adult has the same
hair they did when they were 14 and
thanks in this artwork by Rodriguez Ani
we can easily imagine what Kirishima
would look like if he had a hairstyle
similar to this and I gotta say it
doesn't look too out of place but I know
what you're thinking why would Kirishima
even bother to go back in time when back
ago was the one who was entrusted with
ensuring that one flaw was created there
are two possible answers to this
question so starting with the crazy
theory what if back ago traveled back to
the past by himself and has spent his
entire life in the past building up one
for all but at the end of it he found no
one he deemed worthy of taking on the
power back ago has high standards guys
we know this what if in his time of need
back ago used ones role as a vehicle in
which to send an errand Jaeger style
message to the future in which he tells
the heroes that he needs a successor
that he can trust before he dies of old
age
so when backer go leaves this time
transcending what's that message inside
one for all this would find its way to
Deku in the future who would receive
backhoes message in a vision or dream
quite similar to how he saw the memories
of the first user of one for all and
after this just like in Kamino
dec who would realize that the one
person back ago would want to help him
in this situation is Kirishima and
there's
way that the chivalrous hero read Riya
would turn down the call of his friend
who is literally stuck in the past
instead he'd do the courageous thing and
put his life on the line to ensure that
one for all reaches the present day and
thanks to the beauty of time travel
Kirishima would appear in the past
before back ago ever had the chance to
die without having a successor and yes
this is a paradox but no more so than
back ago being the second user was a
paradox it's basically like an infinite
cycle it just repeats and repeats and
repeats and it's hard to ascertain where
it all originated from that's the
paradox that we don't know what the
quote-unquote first timeline is but if
that was all a little bit too convoluted
for you there's a far more simple
possibility as to why Kirishima was the
third user
what if bakugan Kirishima was sent back
in time together in order to ensure that
backing up could fulfill his mission and
perhaps to help him make more rational
decisions when trying to convince the
first user to pass on his quark in this
scenario things would be a bit different
because they'd obviously aged at the
same rate because they went back in time
at the same time that would mean that
when baku go become zan old man or if he
becomes an old man Kirishima would also
be old as well so the only way for
Kirishima to get one-for-all in this
scenario is if back ago like most of the
other users of one-for-all is killed by
all-4-one and passes the quark onto red
right before he dies
and when you look at this panel of the
previous users it's basically a ritual
at this point if you look at the sixth
holder I mean he's literally crying with
his arm blown off as he's trying to pass
on the quark like this quark is cursed
guys but moving on
we know that Dekker will eventually get
to use all the quirks of the previous
users which was one of the many benefits
of Bach ago going back in time and the
same thing would apply to cure Shima's
hardening quark aztec who could use it
for the final battle with sugar aki now
in chapter 241 of the manga horikoshi
put in a harmless joke in which
Kirishima said to Deku that he had
mastered his hard-earned ink work after
Deku was tensing up on stage was giving
an interview now I'm not saying that
this harmless one of joke is evidence of
something but let's just presume that
it's theory about the second and third
users being bakugan Kirishima
let's assume that it is actually planned
out by Hiroshi if that was the case
their panels like this and this are
exactly the kind of subtle crumbs that
an author who's thinking ahead would
plant again I'm not definitively saying
that they prove anything but it's just
something to think about
also it would be kind of handy for
midoriya to have these two quirks as
backview says in this panel that the
other users didn't really have good ones
and with that said we've now explained
what would have motivated Kirishima to
become the third user and we've also
talked about these subtle hints that are
alluding to the fact that Kirishima am
back ago are these second and third
users so with that out of the way I'm
gonna move on to my theory about Kira
Shima's horrific fate after taking one
for all and to do this I want to briefly
explain two things firstly we now know
that Nana she Morris quark was called
float and it basically allowed her to
hover in the air as you would imagine
and this would usually be a pretty
unspectacular piece of trivia until you
couple it with the fact that we know all
for one killed her and in the present
day we've seen him demonstrate the power
to float now if this is her quirk it
shows that all-4-one has no problem
harvesting the bodies of previous
wonderful users and then using it for
whatever purpose that suits him and with
the evidence that we have at hand all
for one's levitation quark was likely
harvested from Nana shmores body and I
know that all for one caused this power
airwalk but just remember guys this is
someone with infinite amount of curves
we don't even know how many Crocs he has
so he can combine various different
quirks and then give them new names it
doesn't mean that he didn't take Nana
she more as floating quark secondly it
was also revealed in the manga that Kyra
Geary who is one of awful ones most
loyal and faithful disciples is actually
just a highly intelligent no move
created from the body of a former you a
student who was on the verge of death
after an accident sure Akuma was
believed to have died but dr. Yoko
somehow recovered his body before he
actually did and then took him to a
hospital in the mountains whilst he was
there he turns her Akuma into a living
almost like a robot that loves all-4-one
blindly serves the league of villains
and switches off when asked any
questions that might incriminate
all-4-one or dr. Hugo this shows us many
things number one that no moon can be
programmed to genuinely have affection
and love for all for one number two they
can look dramatically different from
what we previously believed number three
is that they can be intelligent and
actually have long conversations and
number four is that they can be given
quirks that aren't naturally occurring
but
rather a combination of previously
existing quirks and now guys I'm gonna
tell you how everything I've just
mentioned ties in together and to the
potentially horrible ending for
Kirishima I'll preface this by saying
that I do not want this to happen but
let me know what you guys think
in the same way that they did this
horrible stuff to share a kuhmo what if
Kirishima was defeated by all for one
and his half-conscious body was taken
and experimented with what if they
tinkered with his body in such a way and
taken with his mind in a way that they
had never done before almost like the
first prototype for what was to come
with Kiera Giri many years later what
I'm suggesting my friends and I know
this is a crazy theory but hear me out
what if all for one's body guard who was
permanently hardened skin spiked hair
and an unwavering loyalty to him what if
Kai gantu macchia is what's left of
Kirishima this would play even further
into the concept of a time loop and I'll
show you what I mean when Kirishima was
a kid he had an encounter with gai gonto
macchia that left him feeling frustrated
like he was unable to do anything and he
kind of felt like a coward and in his
frustration he threw a book which then
accidentally activated an old hologram
which was an interview with his favorite
hero it was only after listening to this
interview that inspired Kirishima to
pursue his dreams of becoming a hero and
attending UA which he had previously
given up on it was only through seeing a
gonto machia and having those events
occurred that led Kirishima to then
become a hero and go to UA and after
succeeding in his goals
Kirishima would then become a pro hero
traveled to the past and become the
third user of ones rule he would then be
defeated by all-4-one and have his body
and mind tinkered with until he
literally became the creature known as
garganta machia he would then live on
and the cycle would then repeat itself
again and again and again and again yeah
this is probably the darkest theory that
I've ever come up with but then again
all for one is just an awful guy you
can't say he wouldn't do this
after what he's already done to shiver
kuhmo and Nana shamora even shigaraki
like he killed his grandmother nothing
is beneath this guy what if he took your
regime his body and his hardening quirk
and then built on top of that base by
adding identification quirks and a lot
of other quirks it would just be so
messed up and I hope it doesn't happen
but hey I'm just throwing the idea out
there if you look at him the way his
hard body is structured and the way the
hair spikes
I mean he clearly wasn't born like that
this is someone who's been created in
exactly the same way that Kiera Gary was
Anka gantter machia does have multiple
quirks one of which could allow him to
live for an indefinite period of time
just like all for one but for those of
you who've been paying close close
attention you'll probably have one
burning question if garganta machi is
still alive then the vestige of the
previous one for all user who were
saying is Kirishima surely that would be
fiery as well just like almost one is
and in reply to that I would say number
one well done for paying attention and
number two we literally can't see the
third user at all like he's completely
blocked out so maybe if we could see him
if her cause she would let us maybe he
would be fiery who knows but for
whatever reason horikoshi thought it was
better to have my guy as a black
silhouette where the only thing that you
can really make out is his pineapple
hair and his shoulder decorations so as
long as the third user remains blacked
out like this I'm just gonna theorize
what I want but now that that crackpot
theory is out of the way let's move on
to a reason why Kirishima actually might
not be the third user now whilst I
haven't seen a new hero's rising movie
yet it's been reported that in this
movie we get a good look at all the
vestiges of one for all and what's the
vestige that looks like back ago is
covered in a red aura and has red eyes
which would be expected the one that
resembles Kirishima has a purple aura
with yellow eyes so the color scheme
doesn't really match up here in the same
way that backhoes does you'd imagine
that Hiroko she has big influence over
the color scheme as this was the first
ever color representation of the
previous users like we never seen their
auras before now the fact that the third
user who if it's kurushima his hero name
is literally red raya it'd be kind of
weird that he doesn't have red anywhere
so it kind of makes it seem like it
might not be him but regardless he may
just be hiding it for another time be
sure to let me know in the comments what
you think about these theories
specifically do you think that horikoshi
is hinting at bakugan Kirishima being
the second and third users of one for
all and if he's not then why is he
blacking out these vestiges and also
another question do you think my theory
about giganto macchia
could actually be true like is there a
chance but whatever you think don't
forget to subscribe as I plan to do a
video explaining gentle criminal quite
soon and I have another theory coming in
about the next month or so that will be
about the quote singularity and with all
of that said thanks for watching guys
and peace out
you